[Music]
to talk to the pakistani taliban
her son was among the 132 students
killed at an army public school by the
armed group in 2014.
the pakistani taliban said it was in
revenge for the military's operations in
tribal areas
is now angry at the pakistani government
and military for starting negotiations
without punishing the culprits of that
attack
how do i forget everything they say 80
000 people have been killed you're not
the only one i sympathize with everyone
but how do i forget my dead son
this is wrong they are criminals how can
you forgive murderers
the government says the state has the
right to talk but the armed group will
have to in its words bow its head before
the constitution
in addition to releasing a large number
of its prisoners the pakistani taliban's
demands reportedly include opening a
political office in another country
reversing the merger of tribal areas
with the northern kp province and the
enforcements of its version of islamic
law in pakistan
and while the negotiations are underway
law enforcement teams say they are
carrying out operations against what
they call criminals and terrorists
this is not the first time the
government is talking to the pakistani
taliban or ttp but simultaneously a
database is being established to make
sure they have the details of the
sympathizers the supporters and the
fighters which belong to the group
now pakistan's special security
department says it's implementing a
research-based strategy to understand
trends of terrorism
this new process is helping the police
to carry out hundreds of targeted
operations across the northern kp
province which shares a border with
afghanistan crime and terrorism has a
lot of nexus also they do not have a
very regimented or a structured
organization
they keep moving from one terrorist
group to the other we've been able to
tabulate and then give guideline to our
field units and they are now going for
target operations but pakistan's highest
court is not convinced the strategy to
hold talks is well thought out it's
already summoned prime minister imran
khan and the judges asked him quote are
we going to surrender once again
he was told you brought those guilty to
the negotiating table
all the groups
individuals
and you know the groups they have to
surrender before any talks can succeed
the government maintains the pakistani
taliban have safe havens across the
border in afghanistan
the latest ceasefire was brokered by the
afghan taliban which used its influence
with the pakistani taliban
we are acting as an intermediary and we
can only try we will continue to do it
so that the talk should reach to a
fruitful ending between the two brothers
as the murky talks are in the way
shahana shows us the stain of her son's
blood on his shoe
victims of the pakistani taliban are
demanding justice before making deals
with who they see as murderers
osama bin
laden pakistan